[Music]
on today's show we talked to a new wife
whose marriage is not what she signed up
for we also talked to a mom whose
parents keep buying too many gifts for
their kids
and we talk to a woman who is struggling
with overeating and stress
and new identities stay tuned
[Music]
what's up
hey what are you doing this is john with
the dr john dolone show what's happening
look the lobby has
tons of people in it
it that's not true it's got four
it's got four people there he is there's
number four i'm hey there's a fifth over
there there's people everywhere man we
have a hundred percent increased our our
normal show audience from a couple of
stragglers and people cleaning up to
for alaska
florida
we've got all of america here america
this is so good all right
james listen
hey
before i talk to james
i'll tell you well this is the dr john
dolone's show i'm glad you're here we
talk about mental health relationships
everything and it's
it's the most linear show you'll ever
listen to i like to um
complete all the thoughts trains that we
start is that right james
yeah there's no no enclosed loops here
no
what do you call them uh no unlanded
planes land the plane john land the
plane
um if you are
not a hunter just hit the little uh 15
second thing a few times
so this week was thanksgiving break and
my son and i went out into the woods
james listen
listen
right before dark my son i've been
hunting all day and right before dark
i told my son i'm gonna go for a walk
and just as the sun was going down
and off in the distance i
rustled up a deer and it took off
running
and dude
just like
it felt like terminator 2. i
shot this deer
in full stride
and i was alone in the woods
and i didn't know i wanted to like tell
somebody and that was just me and so i
went got my son
and then
within five minutes it was
midnight
pitch black like being on the moon pitch
black
and we had to get this
deer out of
the other side of the moon not the side
of the moon with the sun facing the dark
side of the moon hashtag pink floyd
and we had to get this deer out of the
woods and it was a
long arduous
frightening
just rough time getting it out but as we
almost got all the way out my son looked
at me and i could barely see him we had
one little light
he just said dad
this is awesome
and man
i thought i was scaring him like i even
pushed it past my limits and i thought
he's gonna be a serial killer but he's
gonna be a nice one it's gonna be good
so that was we had a we had a it was
pretty remarkable father-son time hey
take your kids out into the woods it's
good for everybody and no killing's not
fun and it's not great and all that
stuff but it's real and it's life and
i think that one of our main challenges
with our mental health challenges in
this country is disconnection from
everything from sleep from food from
death from everything and there's
something very primitive and raw and
very real about
taking the life of an animal and no
one's going to provide provision for
your family for a month on end
and it's a pretty cool time together man
what'd you all do james well i was
working on a peta sponsorship over the
break for your show and that's out the
window now so yeah
they're they're not
yeah they're not huge fans no we had a
good quiet thanksgiving just our family
it was wonderful to sit around and stare
at each other play the recorder
no but we we always go get the tree and
start decorating for christmas the day
after thanksgiving so that's a fun
tradition so joy for the
james charles family is just
no other humans just us
i like that i may or may not have read
it louisa may alcott's story about
thanksgiving to the kids we're pretty
homeschooled at our house
and then we went outside and uh made our
own pencils it was good
it was awesome we made a batch of uh
shaving cream for the for the winter it
was it was excellent good job james
that's awesome
all right that's it let's go to
danny
is that it danny all right danny in
billings montana what's up danny how are
you doing
hey dr john how are you so good how
about you
i am hanging in there
that sounds
come on hanging in there
it's pretty cold so you know do what you
can do oh how cold is it
um it's like five right now nope
nope
nope there are some people who believe
in hell and people who believe in hell
think hell is hot and i might disagree
because you know what hell sounds like
five degrees five that's what's that
planes trains and automobiles he's like
alcohol is it out here one
ah five degrees okay so yes i can see
you're hanging on there that's not great
so other than that though what's going
on
yeah so um i'm calling because um so i'm
24 years old i love you now i love the
way you're dancing around this this
is so good okay so you're 24
yep i've been married now for about six
months
um and two months into
uh my husband met in my marriage we um
took custody of his two kids so full
custody of his six-year-old and
ten-year-old um from his previous
marriage
and i
i don't know
i'm just kind of here and going along
with it and figuring it all out so
before that um they're from alabama and
so we
were just kind of there with them what
do you what do you mean you're going
along with it
they're your kids that's your husband
what do you mean
are you not a huge fan
um i
never really thought say it out loud say
it out loud are you not a huge fan i
mean
i mean i'm not i mean i love them
um but i never thought i was gonna have
kids and so part of the reason
that i think it was so appealing to be
with him is because he didn't want any
more kids
and had these two wonderful kids to live
with their mom who was doing really
awesome
and then she fell into
opiate addiction and so now they're with
us full-time so they've gone through a
whole lot
and
i'm going through it too yeah
so you've got two
kids who've i mean they've got a lot of
trauma coming yeah to move with in with
that in the middle of the year
from alabama to
five degrees
to new mom who's 24 how much older is he
than you
he's 31 31 okay so stop that's not a lot
um okay she said
you said you didn't want kids but you
married a guy with two kids
it seems like the algorithm doesn't work
do what i know
they didn't live with us though and i
thought oh it'd be so great they're
gonna be there we can be there and
support them
but not i guess be in it full time as
selfish as that sounds
and now
we're here and we're doing it all full
time and
doing all the extracurriculars and all
the schooling and taking them to
counseling and doctor's appointments and
all those things it's
a lot
so i can hear you smiling
almost so hard because if you stop
smiling you're going to start crying is
that where you're at
yep yeah
yeah
so
how can i help because yeah you're there
like it's here are you thinking about
leaving the marriage
um because i don't know what you signed
up for kind of
yeah but it's kind of what i've been
thinking about most of the time
but these kids also so they lost their
stepdad to overdose
and so i'm
so scared to be
somebody else that leaves them after all
this trauma that they've been through
yeah but so it's also
i'm worried for them to have a
new maternal figure in their life that
doesn't like them
i mean i do love them and you love them
but you don't like what they've done to
your precious little life yeah you know
what i mean
yeah and it's just hard to accept that
and not feel so
selfish
why is it hard to accept that you
like
you married a guy with two kids and now
those two kids are there and
like this is our life now
like what do you think you're missing
out on
i think before we
had the kids with us here we were
out all the time adventuring and
backpacking and climbing and
we're just all over the place doing
everything and now we're
you know
taking the kids to taekwondo lessons and
going to dance lessons and it's just my
whole life has gone from doing what i
want to do when i want to do it to
living by this other schedule
yeah and so
it just feels like everything has
changed and my relationship has changed
so drastically
what's your husband say when you tell
him all this
um
so we just started marriage counseling
he's
i guess
understanding but
worried
yeah he should be because his wife's
about to leave him
yeah
he should be real worried
yeah
and he's also got his fair share of of
mental health challenges he's a
he's a vet who has some some ptsd things
he's struggling with and so it's
just
i don't know it just all feels like a
mess all the time yeah
what part of this can you control
i can control how engaged i am with kids
and
i don't know i try to control it in the
most like microwaves like making sure
that they have the healthiest lunches
possible every single day
no no no with with that you're talking
about duty and you have a duty right now
because you did you adopt them were you
part of the adoption
um no we we can't yet okay
have you started that process
no we have to wait quite a few years
okay so they're just living in full
custody with dad right now
correct okay so
back out before you start the duty stuff
you're playing mom right now and you're
playing caregiver you're basically being
like a like a big babysitter
and
you were married for six months to
somebody and now that's all sideways
like
what can you control inside your own
head
all right let me let me ask another way
are you done
because if you're done say you're done
and say it out loud
if you
are grieving the fact that the world
just went sideways on you
i think you signed up for this that's
just what it sounds like you married a
guy with two kids and you can't be
stunned the two kids know
that the guy with two kids now has two
kids
um but it is a different arrangement
than you and your
heart
were hoping for
um
but
you can either just be done and walk
away or you can grieve this it's a mess
it's not what it was we used to be able
to run the world and do everything and
now our world is different
and now
how do we make desire how do we practice
desire how do we love one another how do
we have crazy fun adventures in hikes
and crazy fun sex and crazy fun stuff
and still raise a ten-year-old and
six-year-old like how do we do those
things together
um
or
like man i'm out
like it feels like those are your two
choices
or the third one is which help the third
one is actually what most people choose
danny which is i'm just gonna stay in
this and be miserable for the rest of my
life that's how most people do it
yeah it's kind of where i feel like i am
right now like teetering on this
decision
don't choose misery
yeah don't
so convince me that these two kids and
that your husband that you loved a lot a
few months ago
um convince me they're not worth
creating a brand new wild adventure for
your life
like what are you missing
um
i guess
let me get this way here let me ask this
way so i used to live in houston in a in
a big city and
in my head i was always going to
concerts and astros games and sporting
events and things like that
then we moved out to west texas where
there's not a major sports team there's
college teams and things like that but
i'd always talk to my wife about wanting
to get back to the city back to the city
back to the city back to the city and
then finally one day she just called me
on and said what what is it about the
city
and because our life's very similar to
what it was it's like no man the astros
came but
and she
she nailed me up to the wall using ugh
data
i went to about one or two games a year
and i went
like on a big fishing trip to the beat
like to galveston like once a year
and i went to concerts like two or three
times a year
yeah and i did those same things in west
texas because i would drive to houston
and i'd go to like two concerts we'd go
to astros game and i'd go fishing like
so my life really hadn't changed
my
fantasy about what my life used to be
that's what changed yeah
here i'm saying
so what would you
what are you actually missing
i think
what i'm missing the most is a world
that's not
controlled by other people so we're
still in all of this court stuff in and
out and
it just feels like every
day all my decisions are being made by
somebody else
okay unpack that all your decisions
brushing your teeth
no when you go to the bathroom
no where are you going to the bathroom
gross go in the bathroom don't be
disgusting like go on an actual potty uh
i said potty because i have a
five-year-old that's ridiculous i meant
to say toilet i live in the woods though
so you can i live in the woods too it's
so great you can go wherever you want to
man
um do you have pets
we don't
okay who decided that
see like the the all language what what
what decisions are being decided for you
uh
i guess my general daily schedule
outside of work and personal time okay
like um like
what i'm doing in the evenings
what i'm doing on the weekends okay what
are those what are those things
like
taekwondo
um and doing have you ever taken
taekwondo
no
how incredible would it be if you signed
up for taekwondo you'd become a ninja
i mean i guess my kid really likes it
yes
so here's what i'm saying here's here's
what i'm getting at here's what i'm
getting at okay and i'm trying to smile
through it because i know it's hard for
you okay
um
here's the thing
the world took a left turn on you
for whatever reason whatever we you and
i could debate all day long whether what
your role in this is
i think it's high you think it's
probably low
that's a fun drinking game
more real more important is here's where
you're at
yeah
and your ultimate question is what am i
going to do next
am i going to leave my husband who i
loved a few months ago
um in our fantasy life that we lived as
a 24 year old
um
i didn't want kids and now i've got two
even though i'm married again with two
kids
and i got now i got two and i'm making
lunches and i have to ask myself am i
gonna trade the random camping trip or
the random hiking trip
for taekwondo classes
am i gonna trade sitting on the couch
watching netflix for taking kids to
school
am i going to trade
ordering in
doordash for making a healthy dinner for
you know or having my kids teaching kids
how to make dinner for themselves and
all of us doing that together you're
gonna have to yourself ask yourself that
but what i don't want you to do is to
use words like all and everything and no
more and those big
catastrophic end of times words because
they're uh they're they're almost always
not true
so here's your homework assignment are
you ready
i am homework assignment number one i
don't think you fully told your husband
how bad things are have you
it's starting to come out in counseling
but yeah so you haven't told them i'm
not there yet you need to look him in
the eye and say i'm considering leaving
you
if you are indeed doing that
or
if you need to say out loud
my whole world exploded i know yours did
too this is not what i signed up for and
i'm working through what it's going to
look like for me to be here that's a
fair thing to say that's an honest thing
to say and you need to say that out loud
because then you both can work on what
that looks like if you just him haul
around and like i don't know i'm just
thinking about
man that gets messy and he thinks he's
he's helping out and he's not because
he's not getting at the root issue okay
and by the way you're gonna make him
crazy because he's going to think he's
the problem
and the problem right now is your
choices and then the third thing is i
want you to write down these stories
because you got a lot of stories in your
head
stories about what you wanted for your
life what happened to you what's fair
what's not fair i don't have any time
left i've got no whatever left all my
whatever i want you to write those
stories down every one of them
and then i want you to draw a line
across the page and demand evidence is
this one true
is every one of my decisions now over no
am i able to pack up and go camping
anymore no i'm not allowed to do that
anymore because i got two 10 year old
and a six year old
can we get babysitters and still go
camping can we after
you know the shock of two a ten-year-old
and a six-year-old joining our house can
we get back to a great sex life can we
get back to date nights can we get back
to these things and answer all that is
yes it's just if you want to work for it
or not
yeah
yeah and so my question for you is this
are you do you want to work are you
going to or not
i i think you're out
yeah i don't know yet
i hope you're not
i hope you will
create a whole new adventure and you'll
stick it out i really do and not just
because of the kid i mean there's
there's all that but
for you i think you've got a monster
adventure ahead of you
of course it's gonna be hard and brutal
and completely different than you
thought
but man
it could be so much better than you
could have ever dreamt
but it sounds to me like you're done man
yeah
yeah
i don't know yet
i see i don't believe you i think you do
know and you don't want to say it out
loud and that's fair i won't force you
to do it on the on the internets on the
podcast
i want you to practice i want you to
pretend you're staying
pretend you're staying
for 30 days
and go all in and all in means you're
going to be honest with your husband
going all in means you're going to
attempt to get some skills that you
don't have right now
going all-in means you're going to
sign up for a class that you never
thought you would take like taekwondo
that you're going to get a cookbook i
don't know if you ever bought one of
those before whatever it is once you go
all in for 30 days i want you to tell
your husband i'm going all in for 30
days but i'm really nervous be honest
with him
don't let him drown
all alone at the end of this thing
i think you guys sound awesome at the
end of this one
don't bail out dan we'll be right back
from the dr john delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back jack let's go to
trisha in where is trisha columbia
missouri what's up trisha how are we
doing
good how are you so good
things going okay
yeah thanks for taking my call of course
you got it what's up um i have a
question about christmas gifts
um so my husband and i we have three
young daughters
and a small house and then we have
several grandparents and family members
who buy for our kids
and
i have really
tried to encourage my family to
you know buy gift cards or
not to just you know
buy them a ton of toys and it
it doesn't seem like people are really
on board there's been some pushback and
i'm just trying to figure out like how
can i
politely
ask them to please not buy us just
millions of toys
um without you know
crossing boundaries there and offending
people
trisha why do you
why do you hate christmas
i i love christmas
i just messed with you
um more importantly why do you hate
america and toys i'm just kidding
um but in all seriousness why do you
hate your children
no but like legitimately i'm just
kidding
okay so listen um
are your parents
and your in-laws
is this a power move or do they love
your kids and they have a picture of
what that love looks like and they're
trying
to
live their picture of love out or are
they is this a flex for them
both both yeah absolutely
uh for for some of them it seems like
you know they they do this out of love
and they want to get that that one gift
that makes their eyes light up when i'm
just like begging them let's just play a
game you know buy buy a game and play
that with them and that'll make their
eyes light up but yeah peg a kid with a
uh water balloon that'll light their i
mean yeah give them a stick and like a
bucket of mud they'll have a blast right
right um by the way and then i'm like is
it me am i trying to like control too
much because i'm a bit of a control
person yeah i mean you're the worst you
are the worst
no i'm totally kidding no not at all
okay let's call this out so when this
airs it will be after christmas and so
you're gonna be we're gonna be we're
talking right now to a group to
bajillions of people whose
parents either underdid it or overdid it
and or left in the the aftermath of that
right
um so before i give you some some of my
thoughts on this let me ask you one more
question
is there any part of you and it's okay
if i'm way off that your parents out by
you
out purchase you and you feel less than
is there any of that at play here or no
no not from my parents i i would hate to
say it on air for fear that they might
actually hear
but i i feel like so for some of them
it's like well
this makes up for the other you know
362 days a year that we don't see then
ah okay cool so they're they're buying
your love
or they're great
yeah
have they ever said that or is that just
your interpretation
no that's just my interpretation okay so
here's what i want you to do and you say
you're a control freak you love being in
control and the boss
yes
are you married
yes
to who
to my husband okay good answer um
do you just did you beat him did you
tell him what to do and do you pick his
clothes out
uh oh no he asked me to and i refuse
okay i'm trying to gauge the level of i
did that but i'm like i'm trying to
gauge the level of light of control
frequency
no no no here's something you can
control starting right this second
okay
and some of it may be a stretch and i
don't know either of your families and
so just go with me on it okay
okay i want you to imagine a world
that both
sets of parents aunts and uncles
whoever's buying gifts for your kids for
your three little ones
have the greatest hearts in the world
not a single
bad intention they want their grandkids
their nieces and nephews to have the
greatest christmas ever
and what they remember about christmas
is a couple of things
they didn't have the money to buy you
and your brothers and sisters what they
wish they could have and so they always
had that little like just door knock
in the back of their minds of shame
if they had worked a little bit harder
had a little bit different job whatever
there may be that part of them that they
don't get to see them very often and
they want to want them to remember
granddad and they want to remember
grandma and so they buy a little bit
more there is some of that
um but at the end of the day
all of their buying all of their
purchasing is rooted in
a desire to give their kids a magic
christmas so will you will you
can you live in that myth with me for a
minute
yes okay
so there's this psychological
i don't know what to call it it's called
fundamental attribution error right
um
and that is where you get into somebody
else's head
and decide why they're doing whatever it
is they're doing
and that's not a decision that you get
to make because you're not in their head
right
we do it a lot with our husbands and
wives like oh you didn't do the dishes
because you think i'm not pretty anymore
and how do you feel you know right and
we just go down a rabbit hole and really
they didn't do the dishes because they
have diarrhea and they're trying not to
go to the bathroom right so
um what i want you to do is to get out
of their heads
and just stay firmly in your head is
that cool
yes okay so
here's a great thing you can do
give them alternative pathways for their
love
so have you ever said
our kids are really looking for
zoo passes
or movie passes or they want to go to
the jungle gym park or they want to
whatever the thing is art classes
they've really want to take violin
lessons this year and they want to have
violin lessons for the year or they want
to play t-ball and it's expensive with
three kids and t-ball would you be
willing to pay do you see what i'm
saying like some of those are high
dollar things
that you offer them pathways for this
stuff
the second one is
to answer your original question
no you have to set boundaries and there
is no easy way non-hurting feeling ways
to set
boundaries because the key component of
a boundary is it's what makes you
comfortable you know it's what makes you
well and your family whole
and then other people get to decide how
they respond to your boundaries
especially if you put them in place with
treating people with respect if you call
people and like you guys suck you always
buy too much stuff what yeah then you're
[ __ ] but if you call and you send an
email and say this year this is what
we're doing for christmas we're not
buying any toys this year
or me and dad are taking care of all
toys this year here's what we're looking
for
and you put it out there and they choose
to throw a fit that's their grown-up fit
to throw and that's
then you just get to respond to their
temper tantrum that makes sense
yeah
so go back to my suggestion number one
have you tried that to have alternative
paths for them
um in the past yes didn't work they just
said yeah whatever we're buying dolls
well yeah it's cut because it's not like
instantly gratifying for them they don't
get to see like that instant
uh you know look on their eyes
um
on their face but
i don't know i think they just like them
to open it and see it right there yeah
have you
have you told them you can buy all the
toys you want
98 percent of these are going to give
away the day after christmas by the way
i i told
my mom that and she got really upset
actually
and so what does really upset mean
um
well she was like well we just won't do
it this year then
did you say great that's so good
right
and because like wearing baby stuff too
so i'm like i'll just sell it
and you know it it just instantly just
offends people and
yes
so maybe don't say it
why in all honesty why don't you want
them to buy your kids gifts they buying
too many of them are they you don't like
what it's like
what's the your main challenge with it
i think because our house is smaller and
it you know with when you have six sets
of people who are buying and then you
come home with a van load each time and
it's it's very overwhelming especially
when you see them each day and they
don't play with most of what they have
it's just kind of frustrating
another thing you could try is to tell
all of your your children after it's all
so here's i learned this from my wife
uh and i'm spitballing this you may say
john you're dumb you should have another
radio show because this is stupid
um my wife the day after halloween the
kids get to pick out like five or ten of
the their favorite pieces
and the rest go in the trash
and i wonder if the day after
new year's they have a week of playing
with toys
you let your parents get it all out you
don't try to parent your parents you
don't get in their heads and try to
figure out why and they're
psychologically malfunctioning and
they just buy a lot of presents and then
the day before new year's you'd let your
kids know on new year's day
we're gonna take these clothes down i
mean these clothes these toys down to
kids who didn't get any toys for
christmas
and we're gonna um help them have a
magic new year
and so pick your three favorite ones and
the rest of them we're all going to take
down and donate them
and then you have a hard conversation
about
choice and service and but it becomes a
learning lesson and then your kids get
to give toys away
and then in a maybe a day they're sad
about it and then two days later they
they won't remember any of that
right is that a viable option
yeah
okay
i
in my head this is not something to go
to war over number one
but number two
i think your boundaries are your
boundaries and
have you firmly emailed everybody and
said this year we're not doing gifts or
i'm asking you to please not buy gifts
for our kids
but we'd like to do these things like
that i mean have you had that
conversation
yes
and it didn't go well
um depending on which person
okay like it went over okay you know
with with some and not so ah there's one
one set of parents just bought a bunch
of cool stuff and all the other parents
were just chumps like dude i thought we
were buying gifts
that's
awesome contest so one pic dude
i just say let him go have a contest i
think you should open up this year's
gifts and look at him go seriously this
is how y'all got
y'all just skimping on our kids here's a
fun game who's the lamest grandparents
you all win congratulations
and dude next year you'll have cars
they'll be backing up atvs in your
driveway it'll be incredible
oh i hope so
um yeah be awesome i look i i think you
set your boundaries and be super clear
about it and if they violate your
boundaries you got one or two options
you can say you're not welcome in my
house if you do this again or we're not
coming to your house this year
if you buy a bunch of gifts like last
time
and i would do that if
your dad or uncle tom was an alcoholic
and he was not making
he was making the christmas event not
safe
i would do that if
um i don't know if there was some racist
uncle that was saying a bunch of
nonsense and i don't want my kids around
that trash i don't want to be around
that trap like whatever the thing is i
get there's i'm not going to be around
that
i don't know that i would pull that
trigger on this one
but you're welcome too it's up to you
and if you get a bunch of stuff i love
the idea of teaching kids
that they
are more fortunate than than other kids
or maybe not more fortunate they got a
bunch more crap
and they can choose the three or four
things they're gonna really love and
then they're gonna give those a way to
help other people out and you start to
teach your kids a mindset of giving and
a mindset of service
um
yeah this isn't what i'm going to war
over but i do love boundaries and i
especially love parents who will love
and support boundaries
this is after christmas and so it's
probably too late but
[Music]
if you're
got kids
and they set up a boundary
just listen
for god's sake listen to your kids
boundaries you raised them you should be
proud of yourself we'll be right back on
the dr john delaney show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
oh man we are back off air
james is awesome on air i know what
happens man you're so great off here
like the best
the lights come on
[Music]
funruiner.net.com.org
hey by the way um james charles does
have a
uh tick tock dance video channel
it's some of the best tick tock dances
you'll ever see in your life
and you for sure will have to seek
psychological assistance after you watch
it but the goal for everybody is to find
the channel and i'm not going to tell
you where it is but it exists
oh my gosh it doesn't exist but if it
did
please make that would you do that
i'll get right on that if we get a
million subscribers listen go to youtube
right now i don't know where you are
what you're doing in your life go to
youtube right now and subscribe to the
show if we get a hundred thousand james
is gonna create a dick tick tock dance
from a million to a hundred thousand
that's not well i'm trying to get be
real
my whole life is about the old bait and
switch hey before we take this last call
listen to this
on september 13th
2021
it was episode 162
we had a
i mean
a call that has stayed with me for a
long time
whoo man
um
yeah this is a tough one if you remember
back if you want to go back and check it
out it aired on september 13th 2021
a mom called in and she had just lost
her 14 year old 14 month old daughter to
a drowning accident
and she was pregnant
and she was
wrestling with how in the world am i
going to bring a child into the world at
the same time grieving that type of loss
in that tragic of a lot i mean it was a
mess it was a tough call
and she wrote in
oh it's so great she wrote in and she
says this
clara becomes a big sister
had a call with john a few months ago
about my 14-month old daughter's passing
just wanted to update that clara became
a big sister on october 24th
to a little sister cordelia grace
cordelia has brought some healing to us
during our growth as we continue to
grieve clara's passing
i have a picture if you'd like to see it
thanks again for your help and advice as
we navigate this new season of life i'll
say congratulations on a healthy new
baby and for thank you so much for
writing this back and we will continue
to walk with you as you and your family
heal and celebrate at the same time
life's a mess and y'all are doing it
together um and we're so honored to walk
alongside you so thanks for following up
and um i think the original
show date the original show had a and we
used a pseudonym on that show and so i'm
not going to read the name out here but
you can go back and listen to that show
really remarkable um
remarkable strong woman all right take
one more call let's go to caroline in
philadelphia where i was born and raised
what's up caroline
hi how are you
probably the best ever i probably
overstated that i'm cool how about you
i'm doing well and i'm hoping you can
help me there is a small to quite small
chance that i can help but i will give
my best shot what's up okay
well here's my situation
i am fat
and i know it's not a
knowledge problem it's a behavior
problem
okay and things have gotten way worse
since the pandemic started
and so it's like a stress it's i guess
stress binge
and i need that
okay how long have you so let me back up
you said i'm fat with a
a
period at the end of that sentence a
declarative statement
was that a hard thing to say out loud or
is that a thing that brings you shame or
did you have to work your way up to say
that like walk me through that how do
you see yourself
um
so i think
originally there was a certain amount of
i didn't
believe it was happening or there was
excuses for it
like what and
well
i guess before i would say things like i
have this i have an endocrine disorder
which makes it hard to lose weight or
i'd have excuses about i've got two kids
and i'm busy and what i realized is that
i think my first step is to be kind of
radically accountable for
it and then try and move on from there
okay
so going back to
radical radical
accountability what does that mean
well so right now i'm five foot two okay
and i'm 244 pounds as of today
and in that has a doctor ever has a
doctor diagnosed you as as morbidly
obese
um yeah or i'm right there okay okay
yeah and how long have you wrestled with
this
um
i mean i'll say this i've been
you know i i've kind of flirted with the
200 pound line
for about 10 years where i was just
under that and
and then the pandemic happened
and then i crossed that line okay and i
feel like mentally i realized that
this is something that
um and then i got covered really bad and
i had a friend die of covid who was also
had a weight problem
and i realized i really really need to
take this seriously yeah
there's some terrifying data with
obesity and antibody it's there's some
yeah
there's some really remarkable research
out there on the
correlation between
um
hard code hitting people hard and
obesity so
hey can i tell you this
i'll tell you i'm really freaking proud
of you for saying
no more
like i gotta i gotta i gotta take this
serious
that's hard
yeah
like no i'm serious that's a hard thing
to do because you know
what most do statistically
is they look to their left and the right
they go ah sucks to be them
and they just keep plugging along
it is hard to have a never again moment
most people never do it
how
is this a story you were born into is
this a story somebody started telling
you back in the day are your parents big
and what i'm trying to do is
work is this a lifestyle thing is this a
work thing is this an addiction
is this a
um
i got a bunch of genetic work back um a
month ago with my doctor
i have a genetic they call it the cookie
jar gene
and
he said this is from my doctor the guy's
incredible i'm gonna have him on the
show he said
if you open a package
of whatever
the chances that you can grit your teeth
and will power through it are very very
small at the genetic level
and so like my wife i think i've talked
about on the show she's a serial killer
because she can buy a bag of oreos and
just eat one and then eat one like a
five or six days later and i also think
she eats children i don't know how any
human can do that
if i open a bag of cookies i will eat
the entire thing that day because i love
them and so what he was telling me was
your
your
road through life
will be avoidance
you will not willpower your way through
this does that make so what i'm trying
to get at with you is is this narrative
a part of your life is this a
did this happen after a trauma did this
happen
your parents were big did like where did
what's the roots here
so i wouldn't say my parents are big
okay they're they're not i think what
happened is i was a chubby kid
um and then i became a thin teenager a
thin 20-something
and then around 30
things just
i i think what i realized is
you know i can
maybe it's avoidance like you're talking
about it's i will i will meal prep on
sunday and have the perfectly portioned
breakfast and lunch
and then around this time
i get home from you know work i pick up
my kids from daycare i'm making dinner
for everybody like and then all of a
sudden i'll turn around and i won't even
remember necessarily yeah that i ate
my dinner
and maybe the rest of my kids dinner
and maybe there were two glasses of wine
and i i won't even be conscious of it
yeah
and it's like i'll be so regimented
on so many things and then it's like it
just kind of unravels
usually when i have a lot to do and i'm
stressed out
so walk me through stress for you
what are you stressed from um
well i'm a working mom
and i have two kids who are daycare age
my son's five and my daughter's just
almost two yeah
and you know i'm in a dual income
household
and you know it's like we just
work you know we work and the kids get
sick and then you come home and you hit
like second shift of everything yeah
and and it's just i won't even
necessarily sit down when this happens
what keeps you up
what keeps you up at night like if you
had to tell me two or three things that
freak you out what are they
um
getting it all done i guess being behind
like i never feel like i'm caught up
yeah
never
you know right now even like i'm so
excited for this phone call and all i
can think about is the 20 things i have
to do of course
after it
before bedtime
and then
like i don't have like it's just a
season of life that's just very
stressful and then add the pandemic and
i feel like
like a lot of working moms it all got
thrown on us it did but caroline this
isn't a season
this is a long time
this is years
yeah and this is
a
worthy incredible woman
who is trying to chase down value
like with all you have
to the point that
at certain at certain times of the day
your body disassociates itself
from you from reality
so that it can cope
and then it plugs back in and when the
lights come back on we're just in a
shame spiral and a exhaustion spiral and
we collapse we do the whole thing over
again the next day and the next day and
the next day
yeah
and so
what manifests itself as oh my gosh i
gained 50 pounds in two years what the
what
happened that's a that's a piece of a
story that's been being told for a long
time fair yeah how's your marriage
i mean we're doing i mean we're doing
well honestly it's we had my second
daughter
and then i felt like it was it just was
so much more work like when it was one
kid divided by two parents we did okay
and then it was two kids and then
everybody was home
and
yeah we lost all our help
and i kind of realized how much
that help
i needed yeah
yeah so
there's a lot here and i i'm
it's way outside my lane
to talk about this level of
obesity on on like that's just that's
beyond my expertise ten ten lanes over
okay
have you partnered with a doctor before
um
not
not
radically okay so doctors have talked to
me about it yes weight watchers you know
yeah yeah yeah
so
here's where i want you to start
and as we as we get to
um this show will air
we're doing this between thanksgiving
and christmas so for the listener but
the show will air around new year's
where i want you to start with this is
not on how do i quit snacking or
overeating
this is a much bigger conversation
and i want it to start with an identity
conversation
who am i
and you started this call by saying i'm
fat
i would tell you that's a physical
characteristic
that's not an identity
and some would look at people who are
overweight and say they're lazy that's
an identity
some would say that person's got a lot
going on
both psychologically spiritually
emotionally physically they got a lot
that person's exhausted
that person doesn't have resources that
like whatever identities you want to put
in there
but i'm fat isn't i not an
identity okay
what i've had to do in my life and again
i've never faced anything like what
you're facing okay and so let's be
honest you got a hard road to hoe
because you're not just losing weight
you are changing who you are from the
inside out
i had to when i made some pretty drastic
changes
i had to decide
i am a guy
who will be a good steward of my one
precious little body
and before that i had to decide i'm a
guy
who is worth taking care of
and then behaviors and choices and
decisions all stemmed from those things
i am a guy who's worthy of my wife's
love i'm a guy who's
gonna roll around on the floor with my
kids
i'm gonna last longer than they can in a
wrestling match
and that's an iden that's the kind of
guy i want to be
and so then i had to create a world what
did that mean for me i'd get really
serious with a medical doctor i had to
get really serious with my mental health
i'd get really serious with
a workout regimen and a daily routine
and all these other things but i didn't
start with those things
most people go wrong as they say i want
to lose 100 pounds
and you can lose 100 pounds but you'll
go with you
here i'm saying that same exhausted mom
will just be you 100 pounds lighter and
you'll have shifted to a fifth glass of
wine or to somebody at work or to
another netflix you're just gonna keep
passing that around you get what i'm
saying
yeah i'd love to see you value yourself
so much that you would go get radical
with the doctor
i would love to see you value yourself
so much
that you go get radical with a
workout program with a with a personal
trainer
whatever that is i don't even care what
the program is it could just be jumping
i don't care what it is
anybody who tells you like this is the
one idiots idiots whatever one you'll do
right i don't care okay
i wish you would get so radical with
your heart
and your value and your worth on this
planet and to your husband and to your
kids and to your neighborhood into your
workplace
that you would say these things won't be
in my home that's what we have to do in
my house when i'm out of town my my wife
has
like
they call them like gluten tuesdays or
whatever i mean they'll get pizza and
stuff when i'm gone because that's the
only time i can survive in the home and
all my other kids and their little
rational decision-making or whatever
brains they got i didn't get that and so
we just can't have it in the house and
we all live with it and it's all good
it's cool and we've just made peace with
it and life's great and if there's
marshmallows in the house i'm gonna eat
most of the bag i just am i'm gonna just
dominate it it's cool
um when we have people over we send
leftovers home with them
just to get this right but again it's
about a radical way of living and that's
where you're at but the radical living
starts underneath a new identity
so my question for you caroline is
are you worth being well
yes
do you believe that
90
nope where's that other 10
um
who told you you're not worth being well
somebody told you
who
i think it's just being like saying like
mom comes after kids
no
that's yeah that is a modern myth of a
lie of a nonsense of
trash
if you don't take care of you first
you've got nothing left for those kids
yeah
right
and you're worth being well so are those
kids
would you do me a huge favor
yes
would you be willing to walk with me for
the next year
and check in with us
yeah i'll do that because here's what's
gonna happen either you're gonna come on
the air and say i just screw it
and if you do that i'll high-five you
okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna shame
me i'm not gonna get on to you
um that'll be as real as real can be
or you're gonna make some radical
identity shifts
and decide that you're worth it not just
in spirit only but a full hundred
percent and you're gonna make some
radical behavior choices you're gonna
make some hard phone calls
you're gonna tell your husband you're
gonna tell some of your friends you're
gonna say
this is the year this stops
i'm getting it all back
every bit of it my zest for life my
laughter i'm not gonna live my life
exhausted i'm not gonna live my life 150
pounds overweight i'm not gonna i'm not
whatever those things are
and then i'm gonna go get the i'm gonna
go
lean into the resources that are gonna
make that stuff happen you can't do this
one on your own and you gotta go see a
medical doctor asap okay you promised me
that
i promised that okay you're worth that
and i want you to be as vulnerable with
them as you were with me
okay
do you promise
yeah okay
have you ever listened to the show
before
all the time
okay you got to get some better podcasts
in your feed by the way
i mean for real let's be honest
okay one thing about the show is i never
lie to people okay
do you trust me
i trust you you're worth being well
okay
okay that's cool man
let's go let's go get some beers
i'm serious i'm just processing i know i
know you are i know you are so here's
the here's your
your homework tonight and then i want
you to email it to me tomorrow okay
okay
okay let's get some beers
he's just processing it
um here's your homework i want you to
write down five new identity statements
okay
okay
and they're gonna start with i am
and they're not gonna be physical
characteristics they're gonna be
they're gonna be aspirational identities
here's who i'm gonna become in 2022.
okay five of them cool that sounds good
fair
i think that's fair promise i can do it
i promise tomorrow i 100
believe in you
100
think this is the year
and anybody listen to this whose life
went sideways the last 24 months you're
not crazy and you're not broken
the world went sideways it still is
sideways it's still spinning sideways
the choices
that
our life is now
and then what
we all woke up today with this is what
we've got this is what the choices we've
made this is the decisions we haven't
made this is where we are this is what's
been done to us this is the stories we
were born into these are the stories
we've been told and these are the
stories i tell myself i'm fat i'm broke
i'm dumb i'm filling the blank i suck at
i cheated i fill in the blank whatever
it is
own that story
and then the world is waiting for you to
answer the next one which is now what
now we gonna do
the whole world's waiting what are you
gonna do next
caroline i'm rooting for you
we all are rooting for you there's not a
lot of people listening to the show
let's be honest
just 27 28 actually i got the new
numbers dang there's a lot of people
that's in the show james
it's a lot it makes me uncomfortable so
i just say 17 because i have low
self-esteem caroline's a lot of people
listen to the show and we're all rooting
for you
we're going to walk alongside you this
year we're going to check in with you
every month or so and i look forward to
having this phone call a year from now
oh my gosh what a different world it's
going to be all right so as we wrap up
today's show
sarah the editor of the dr john dolone's
show
she's literally the coolest person in
this building
she chose today's
song of the day her favorite song of all
time
and it's a first on this show
it's the beatles
and the song is here comes the sun and
it goes like this
here comes the sun
doo doo doo doo here comes the sun and i
say it's all right
little darling it's been a long cold
lonely winter little darling it feels
like a year since it's been here here
comes the sun
doo doo
doo doo here comes the sun and i say
it's all right little darling the smiles
returning to the faces little darling it
seems like years since it's been here
and here comes the sun
doo doo
doo doo
here comes the sun and i say it's all
right
son son son here it comes it is already
pitch black outside in nashville
tennessee
oh we could all use a little more sun
right here on the dr john dolone's show